Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you are watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel, in
the video today we’re looking at how a little
girl’s letter inspired Abraham Lincoln to
grow a beard.
In 1860, the clean shaven Abraham Lincoln
was running for President of the United States.
This bare faced look was somewhat odd for
a man of the age.
You see, shortly before Lincoln decided to
grow his now famous facial hair, something
of a beard-olution swept the United States
and by the mid-19th century the formerly predominately
clean-shaven men of America were now nearly
universally sporting beards.
In fact, one reporter, doing a story on the
new trend in 1857, walked the streets of Boston
and after counting 543 men that walked by
him, found that 62% of them were sporting
bushy beards and all but 4 of the rest had
some other type of significant facial hair.
Even those four that lacked any significant
facial hair sported what would later be called
Side Burns, after General Ambrose Burnside.
The clean shaven look that Lincoln at the
time was still clinging too was out of style.
Needless to say, had Lincoln been running
today, his campaign manager would have told
him he needed to grow some facial hair, with
most of the voting populace sporting it.
Instead of campaign manager, it was a little
girl who clued Lincoln in that he needed a
change.
The girl in question was 11 year old Grace
Bedell from New York, who sent a letter to
Lincoln dated October 15, 1860:
Dear Sir
My father has just home from the fair and
brought home your picture and Mr. Hamlin's.
I am a little girl only 11 years old, but
want you should be President of the United
States very much so I hope you wont think
me very bold to write to such a great man
as you are.
… I have yet got four brothers and part
of them will vote for you any way and if you
let your whiskers grow I will try and get
the rest of them to vote for you you would
look a great deal better for your face is
so thin.
All the ladies like whiskers and they would
tease their husbands to vote for you and then
you would be President.
My father is going to vote for you and if
I was a man I would vote for you to but I
will try to get every one to vote for you
that I can I think that rail fence around
your picture makes it look very pretty …. When
you direct your letter direct to Grace Bedell
Westfield Chautauqua County New York.
I must not write any more answer this letter
right off Good bye
Grace Bedell
Apparently not too busy campaigning to answer
the letter of a little girl, Lincoln wrote
her back from Illinois on October 19, 1860:
My dear little Miss
Your very agreeable letter of the 15th is
received – I regret the necessity of saying
I have no daughters – I have three sons
– one seventeen, one nine, and one seven
years of age.
They, with their mother, constitute my whole
family.
As to the whiskers have never worn any do
you not think people would call it a silly
affection if I were to begin it now?
Your very sincere well wisher
A. Lincoln
Lincoln had numerous documented instances
of self-deprecating jokes concerning his less
than attractive visage.
In one such instance, while publicly debating
with his longtime rival Stephen Douglas- after
Douglas called him "two-faced"- Lincoln reportedly
replied, “If I had another face, do you
think I’d wear this one?”
(Note: Douglas was not only Lincoln's political
rival, but also a rival outside of politics-
Lincoln's wife, Mary Todd was courted by both
Lincoln and Douglas originally.
In the end, Lincoln perhaps wished he'd lost
that battle given accounts of his married
life.)
Given his attitude about his appearance, it's
perhaps not surprising that despite not definitively
saying he would grow a beard, after replying
to Grace on October 19, 1860, Lincoln’s
facial hair situation progressed as follows:
But this isn’t the end of the story.
On Lincoln’s trip from Illinois to Washington
D.C., the now President-elect made a stop
in Westfield, New York on February 19, 1861.
On the train platform, he related the story
behind his decision to grow a beard and asked
if the little girl in question was in the
crowd.
She was and approached; at which point, according
to Bedell, he said:
'Gracie, look at my whiskers.
I have been growing them for you.’”
She stated he then kissed her and she never
saw him again.
After Lincoln, every elected President except
William McKinley would sport facial hair.
This trend finally ended when Woodrow Wilson
took office in 1913.
From then on, U.S. Presidents have remained
clean shaven.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it please click that like button below
and also consider subscribing, and do check
out our archives we’ve got almost 700 videos
now so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.